this is paid for it is paid for and far
more by the amount of deficit reduction
that we're already on track for this
year so yes we consider it fully paid
for
fully paid for no one believes that for
a second because the cost of finding
student loan forgiveness scheme just
keeps growing analysis from the
university of pennsylvania's wharton
school of business today said it could
end up costing up to 1 trillion dollars
over a 10-year period that's a trillion
with a t and the questions even from
allies are mounting
i'm not sure biden's policy here works
the other big question about this
decision well i don't disagree with the
decision he's made about this
is will it really have the impact
they're hoping for with younger voters
joining me now is dr ben carson
neurosurgeon and former trump hud
secretary dr carson you grew up in a
single-parent household you worked your
tail off to get where you are what kind
of message does this send to kids who
were in your position at one time
well it's a it's a horrible message
rachel uh thanks for having me
uh first of all this is not helping the
inflation situation
it's clearly unfair to others who've
worked very hard to pay off their debt
um you know i borrowed a total of eleven
hundred and fifty dollars
uh when i was going to college i was at
yale they had something called a tuition
postponement option you paid back not
according to what you borrowed but how
much money you made so i paid it back
multiple multiple times yeah and once i
got on the board you know it was one of
the first things that i worked to get
rid of because it was unfair and that's
really the issue here this is supposed
to be a country where we have liberty
and justice for all and yet now we have
this plan
with the debt cancellation
over 500 billion dollars right there
loan forbearance another 16 billion
the uh income driven repayment plan
another 70 billion i mean the amount
just keeps going up and that's assuming
that everything is static it's really a
bailout for those people who don't need
a bailout who are already on the pathway
to financial success and you're asking
people
who can least afford the middle class
and the poor to pay for it how in the
world is that fair and it's it's sort of
the same mentality that says we don't
care that the southern border is open
and all these people are flooding across
even though it's unfair to the people
who stood in line and waited and did it
the right way
we don't care
yeah and they they sort of decide design
and define what is fair and it's not
what's fair yeah i mean there's a lot of
talk about how it's a you know a way to
woo young voters to you know bribe them
but it's also a payoff to the
universities who've been doing the work
for the democrats of indoctrinating
students and creating little democrats
oh no question about that
and and that's a whole nother issue
why should the federal government with
federal dollars
be sponsoring indoctrination centers
yeah and you know at some point people
are going to have enough courage i i
hope to actually deal with that
situation yeah i have we have on screen
a graph here of just how much tuition
has increased it's it's it's a travesty
because
this policy this debt forgiveness uh dr
carson is going to do nothing to solve
the underlying root problem which is the
outrageous
increase
in college tuition
well the amount of money in private uh
colleges
average 51 000
and when you get into your more
expensive ones you're pushing 70 80 000
it's ridiculous yeah and it's no wonder
that some people are deciding that they
don't want to do it anymore
yeah well they're sitting on massive
endowments as well but they're asking
for money
from the middle class and the poor as
you said dr carson so great to have you
tonight thank you for your insights
thank you rachel hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else